all right y'all before we dive into this
episode and man was it a great episode
we had two friends two new friends on
the podcast didn't wait yeah yes the
great guys great guys well in gal and go
sorry great guy in gal you're using gal
gender-neutral exactly yes you're
appropriating Geico do that anyway we
had Lewis Howells on here whose new book
just came out it's called The Mask of
masculinity but then we also had the
very talented musician Rayleigh Nicole
she performed the song during our added
value segment and man was was it great
god that was awesome we just finished up
an event where we've been on tour we did
a tour stop here in Dayton Ohio and I
just got to say thank you Dayton it was
it's we've done four or five tour stops
over the years in our hometown Dayton
Ohio
and man it was it was truly amazing
and there must've been a thousand people
that showed up I you know they say you
can't be a prophet in your own town
[ __ ] oh yeah we did leave the town
yeah it was it was an unbelievable
turnout I I was floored with with how
many people showed up i yeah Dayton we
love you so much
man I was thinking like people always
ask me like why do you love Dayton Ohio
so much and I can tell them things like
it's an unassuming City or it's really
blue-collar
or it's not pretentious at all and those
things are true but this sort of
approximates why I love it
every time I come here we're actually
we're in a recording studio right now in
Dayton Ohio and every time I come here I
just it gives me that emotion that I
feel and only a handful of cities that
I've ever been to and every time I come
back it's like a magnet it draws me back
in and it just feels so good to have our
hometown all show up people from all of
Ohio were here Indiana Kentucky Michigan
Pennsylvania people from all over the
Midwest came and just thank you so much
speaking of being on tour we just
announced the Australia and New Zealand
tour Oh put a shrimp on the barbie
you guys stop saying that oh so so yeah
we're coming you can just go to the
minimalists calm you can find all of our
tour dates there
we're also we saw a bunch of cities left
in the US this year we're gonna be in
Texas we have a three stops there
including a charity stop for Houston
help out with the flood relief efforts
and the rebuilding there in Houston
we're gonna be in Tennessee Washington
DC in Georgia Florida Michigan and
Wisconsin a few of those are already
sold out most of them are really close
to selling out just head on over to the
minimalists comm to get your tickets oh
and by the way it's not on our tour page
yet becoming really soon we're getting
ready to announce this Las Vegas State
huge tragedy just happened in Las Vegas
we want help out the victims fund there
so a hundred percent of the profits it's
going to be January 14th at the house of
House of Blues in Las Vegas
the details will be on our website if
you want to be the first to know to sign
up for our email list over at the
minimalists comm you'll get all our new
SASR show notes to all of our podcasts
but also any new events and news from
the minimalists actually the very first
people to know will be our patreon
supporters you'll have access to the
presale tickets before they go on sale
to the public all right Ryan I think
that's a maybe we should turn them over
to this episode unleash the episode
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without him welcome to the House
of Blues in San Diego California
my name is Joshua fields Milburn and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalists and this is a special
edition of the podcast because we are
bringing a good friend of ours out here
and someone who I just I think he's a
great person he's really inspirational
and well I'll give you the full intro
when he gets out here ladies and
gentlemen Lewis Howes is here tonight
all right now it's not just because he's
a fellow Ohioan and he now lives out
here in California he so he wrote a
great book called the school of
greatness he runs a podcast by that same
name the school of greatness if you're
not familiar with it you should be
because he interviews just some really
amazing people and you've got a new book
coming out in fact when this podcast
comes out we're gonna wait until October
Halloween to put this podcast out
because Luis has a new book called the
mask of masculinity that's coming out
can you talk a little bit about what
inspired you to put that out there
they're clapping about the book oh yeah
they're clapping all right what inspired
me to bring it out yeah so I'll just
give you a little back story
My partner Rebecca and I were having
lunch with Louis last month and the
thing that was there was they really
stood out to me about the book is it
wasn't just like a book for dudes about
masculinity right it was it was almost
like a guide an everyday guide into the
male psyche a little bit it was almost
like a recipe book for it to help better
help women I know that Rebecca was she
was sitting there with you and like the
light bulb was going off like oh I so I
can better understand that these sort of
masks that men wear and that's it I
think it's a book for men but I think
actually 90% of the readers are gonna be
women because we break down a number of
the different masks that men wear why
they wear it and how you can get them to
take it off without making them wrong
right so talk to me about one of the
masks like what's one that stands out
the Joker mask okay the guy who always
has to lead with humor always makes a
joke in any situation when even when
he's not supposed to make a joke right
and can never really just connect and
just allow for a moment of whatever
happening besides humor and and so what
what's what's the reason that we put on
these masks usually some type of pain
trauma bullying disconnection it's a
defense mechanism each one is a defense
mechanism to achieve some type of
greater mass
unity to prove our manhood that were
worthy men yeah in the world and
essentially to say that we're worthy of
love yeah
yes indeed and and so speaking of pain
or trauma you've gone through some stuff
in in your own life you know back in
Ohio we all have like these sort of
inciting events or there could be
tragedies like with my mother dying and
my marriage ending or it can just be
like Ryan and he was like why the hell
was my friend so happy and he's not
supposed to be right and and we have
these inciting incidents for you it was
a little bit different can you talk
about about well you spent some time on
a couch yeah I mean I was I used to talk
about how you got on this is the tenth
year anniversary of me losing my dream
and starting a new life and I used to
play arena football which it was never
good enough to play in the NFL but I
still got paid $250 a week to play
football so I call myself former
professional athletes cuz I did get paid
and I got injured I broke my wrist I was
diving into a wall arena football dough
window wall and broke my wrist and that
was in the second game of the season and
then for the next fourteen games I
played with a broken wrist at the end I
had to have surgery that took a bone out
of my hip put it into my wrist and so I
was in a cast for six months like this
like the kid from the movie Rookie of
the Year did you ever see that although
I didn't have superhuman strength and
threw a hundred-mile-an-hour fastball
when I got the cast off I could barely
move my arm for the next year so I was
sleeping on my sister's couch trying to
recover and figure out you know who am i
number one because I lost my dream what
am I gonna do next how am I gonna make
money
everything about my identity was
shattered now I still lived in America
you know had a family and you know how
to place to live so it wasn't like I was
starving but essentially everything I
thought I knew I didn't know anymore and
so I had to figure out what's the next
steps for me what's the next move and
that was ten years ago well I think that
I think that we all we all get to this
point and we realized like you know what
I need to I need to turn this around
or the other thing could happen quite
often we spiral in the other direction
you know I think would have been really
easy easy for me when when my mom died
and the marriage ended like it's like
getting into two car crashes at the same
exact time and it would have been easy
for me to just like to spiral downward
and and or you you can you can learn
from that car crash and I think you can
you can sort of move forward so so ten
years ago you decided to move forward
can you talk a little bit about how that
happened it started with mentors I just
said I need to how can I translate what
I knew from the sports world into real
world into life because sports are not
life's but I said how can I translate
those principles and right away I just
said I need to find a mentor or coach
someone who can teach me because that's
the only way I learned sports is through
a coaches right
so I started seeking out local mentors
in Columbus Ohio which is where I was
living through LinkedIn my one mentor
said why don't you get on LinkedIn see
if we can find some opportunities so I
spent all my days on LinkedIn connecting
with influencers in the community and
asking them if they would take me out to
lunch because I couldn't pay for their
lunch Wow yeah
and this is one of the reasons why today
whenever I go out to eat I think you're
with me I mean I don't let anyone pay
for my meals even if there's ten of us
yeah I feel like I have to pay for
everyone because for a couple years I
couldn't pay for lunch and I always felt
so embarrassed that I could not pay my
own meal you feel like you're paying it
forward now I do yeah well paying it
back and paying it forward yeah yeah I
got a lot of money on lunches well you
know what's interesting is someone
asking other that I was talking to
someone letting know that Lois was gonna
be here and when I described who he is I
said he is a professional minty and and
what I mean by that is like I thought
you were so good at learning from other
people you are constantly asking
questions and and never afraid to ask
questions man
and I know that most people get get
stuck by they get paralyzed because they
feel like well if I don't ask the
question in the in the exact right way
or I can I'll frame this correctly I'm
gonna thin someone and and with you
somehow you you were able to get over
that and and you're constantly asking
questions I feel like I'm I'm asking
questions of you and I'm learning how to
better ask questions every time like I
spent some time with you because you're
always asking questions and and you're
always just like searching and and in a
way it reminds me of that that childlike
curiosity you know I've got a four year
old and she's console asking questions
and she couldn't care less what I
thought about her questions right she's
constantly asking why and how and and
where and and I see the same thing with
people who were constantly growing and
so how do you get to that point where
you're comfortable with with asking
questions because I feel like you're
just always learning something my dreams
are the most important thing in my life
and the only way to achieve my dreams
are for me to grow the only way for me
to grow are to do the most uncomfortable
things in the world for myself the only
way to know what those uncomfortable
things are to listen and ask the right
questions yeah definitely and I think
the the especially in this culture you
know we are so comfortable we have we
have all the comforts no matter I mean
even when I was growing up really poor
on on food stamps and government
assistance like it was you know we still
had assistance there in a way right and
we we had at least a lot of basic
comforts and we we get we fall to this
place of complacency and I found it
especially when I was in the corporate
world and Ryan I know you experienced
this too when you get to this point
where you're not really contented by the
life that you're living but you're too
comfortable to do anything about it and
I think sometimes we just have to force
ourselves into that discomfort so that
we can give ourselves the opportunity to
to grow to change to be you know the
version of ourselves that we want to be
so I'd love to answer some questions
here tonight we've got a microphone here
in the middle
and oh by the way we've got we've got
someone filming some stuff here any of
you all see our documentary yeah so our
director Matt Dee Avella ladies and
gentlemen we certainly could have not
made that film without him he is I mean
he's exceptionally talented you could
check him out he has a bunch of
webseries and stuff online as well it
was his first feature film we're filming
some stuff now I don't really know how
it's all going to pan out we're working
on a special and some shows and all
kinds of stuff trying to get this
message out there visually in different
ways I got I got a question for the
audience yeah for sure
how many of you heard about these guys
before the documentary
excuse me how many of you did not hear
about them until you saw the documentary
raise your hand if you didn't know who
they were
until the Netflix documentary is about
like half the room yeah for sure
yeah I mean it's really been a way for
us to spread the message you know what
we're doing now is all these different
vehicles so so we started like Ryan said
earlier we started a blog in December of
2010 and like that was a vehicle and
then people started asking us like about
writing books and then we started using
social media and then we started a
podcast and then the documentary and
we're always looking for the right
vehicle to communicate a message
sometimes visuals sometimes it's written
sometimes it's a live event I mean you
can't really replicate this even
listening on a podcast letter you can't
get the same thing that you would have
come into a live event you know we we do
a dozens or I guess hundreds of hugs
after the event in a case like this and
so yeah you can stick around afterward
for that but uh yeah check Matthew vel
out he's got a great YouTube channel
with a bunch of features like little
like many mini documentaries stuff like
that just Matt Diavel accom I guess no
one has any questions goodnight ladies
and gentlemen you got to walk up to the
microphone howdy
what's your name
chrysten were you from from Santa
Barbara but I've lived in San Diego for
about eight years now awesome
welcome yeah Ryan you and I are kindred
spirits because I still drive my 2003
Toyota Corolla nice car I got when I was
16 only card ever owned this is much
fancier the same outfit on - that's all
right
um so I have a question I have met a lot
of people who are very anxious to get
started with the minimalism part because
of the giving away things so what would
you guys suggest as a first step for
somebody who isn't quite ready to start
parting with things that they feel
anxious about parting with but can still
make steps toward eventually getting
there is this that asking for a friend
question no I'm actually my husband's
really happy that I found you guys
because I've gotten rid of a lot of
stuff that I've been a hoarder for a
long time so so what kind of problems
when you say problems what if they're
having issues with letting go I think I
think I'd have to understand what the
actual issue is with that person first
I'm probably just the idea that if they
let go live if they start giving away
things that they're either gonna regret
letting go some of the stuff that they
gave away or that the whole process of
just parting with items is scary and
they don't know what to part with and
what to keep like they might be really I
know I'm sure of what they really want
in their lives and they don't want so
what's not going to them Josh you know I
to the first like snag I ran into when I
was getting rid of stuff like duh the
whole the whole idea of the packing
party was so appealing to me because I
felt like worst case scenario I could
just unpack everything and put it all
back if I really really wanted to now a
packing party for most people is gonna
be a little bit too extreme especially
if you got like you know a family of six
you know you can't just pack up
everyone's stuff
we certainly don't recommend that you do
anything with anyone else's stuff it's
funny we had a gentleman in Atlanta
bring his daughter and he had a question
and he was like I got a question can you
please explain to my dog
why it was good that I got rid of all
her stuff yeah you should not have done
that
um stick to your own stuff but uh but
when I was going through my stuff after
the packing party you know first I
remember making that decision to donate
or sell some of the stuff like I was
thinking like if I'm not gonna get value
out of this maybe someone else can and
some other stuff I was holding onto just
because I had this like perceived value
like oh man this is worth X amount of
dollars so I was like great I'm gonna go
ahead and say I don't use it anymore so
now I'm gonna you know get that value
out of it and now you know the older
that especially technology gets the less
I would be able to get out of it but I
remember I'm inviting Josh over to just
kind of help help me go through stuff
and I remember at one point like I look
over and he's got you know big 50 gallon
black trash bag and he's just like
sweeping coffee cups into it and I'm
like what are you doing man like I was
like I drink coffee he's like yeah but
you got like 30 cups like well why do
you dirty 30 coffee cups like that's a
lot of dishes to do actually it was 40
and I'm like nah man like what if one of
those breaks and you know and then
another 29 of them break
I've got backups to the backups and and
you know it was very hard for me to like
just let even play coffee cups and then
the first thing that that really stood
out to me was like the first rule that I
made for myself Josh was like he picks
up this coffee mug and it's like you
know it says like world's number-one
granddad on or something and he's like
what's the last time you use this cup
and I was like I couldn't even tell you
and I remember thinking right there I'm
like okay like I didn't even use that in
the last year I'm probably not gonna use
that in the next year I feel good about
getting rid of that coffee cup but I
took that approach with a lot of the
other stuff too I had to like create
some boundaries for myself and then I
remember you know going through that
pile came across this shoebox that had
some old like high school memories in it
some letters that my mom had written me
that really I just remember getting
those letters in high school and like
how they made me feel I mean just a lot
of sentiment and emotion attached with
those letters picture of me and like my
you know prom my junior you know high
school prom date the the the shot glass
they gave us for our gift I'm laughing
because I'm a therapist and I had a
client asked me if she could see my prom
picture before she showed me her prom
picture and so it's funny because I
actually needed it and I couldn't find
it well I was sitting there I'm like
faced with all this stuff and I was like
well dude you gotta get rid of this
stuff you're minimalist now like there
is no sense in holding on to these
memories so I like take the shoebox and
I'm like trying to you know throw in the
trash and I'm just like like I cannot I
can't do it
so I bargained with myself and I was
like all right I'm just gonna choose
like one thing out of this box I'm gonna
let it go and see what happens see how I
feel the next day so I took a letter
that my mom and written me and I
and what's really weird is like before I
read the letter I remember how it made
me feel when I was in high school but
after like reading and which I hadn't
read it in years it did not have evoked
a completely different emotion so like
the memory of it was better than like
actually reading the letter again so
that was kind of like you know one light
bulb that went off and then I just I
took a picture of it with my camera
phone so I guess technically I still you
know have it in the cloud somewhere oh
but I took the letter I put in the trash
and I was like alright if I wake up you
know if I wake up tomorrow Mike man I
really didn't sleep well last night I
was thinking about throwing that thing
away um I could just go to the trash and
pull it out and I'm even even think
about it until I was like taking out the
trash the next night or even the evening
after that um the letter was sitting
there on top of the trash and I was like
oh yeah that's right that letter and
that is when I was like yeah I'm just
gonna go through this box and I did take
um like a couple photos of things but
for all intents and purposes like I got
rid of everything that was in that in
that shoebox um what I'm trying to get
at is whoever is is struggling with
letting go for whatever reason it is
they've got to start somewhere they have
to start with letting go of something
and the reason why and it just something
really really small but the reason why
that's so important is because you know
a you've got a bit momentum I mean I'm
sure you can speak to you gotta build
momentum somehow to to keep going and
the other thing too is they've got to
realize that letting go isn't that
nearly as hard as as they think it is so
for for your friend or your friend of a
friend over it is that is is you know
stuck with that letting go part I would
say like the first action to take is to
just at least like just start with one
thing and see how it feels and get some
kind of momentum built now if you've got
like a friend who's a monk and they and
they have nothing then I mean I'm not
gonna don't tell him to throw away their
sandals you know like
at the end of the day like you really
have to have a really good reason why
and you know that's the Josh said that
and his talk earlier he's that's where
it started for him was asking that
question of how might my life be better
with less and getting the leverage there
that is what will absolutely help them
take that first step
thank you so much you guys thank you all
right it's time for us we're gonna get
to your question don't worry we're gonna
move on to well Ryan what time is it you
know what time it is
it is time for our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning round yes indeed
it'll really usually answer questions
from social media we're on the Twitter's
and the Facebook's and where else are we
Instagram right yak you saw Jessica
Williams here earlier she handles all of
our social media and she also does the
merch booth and all that other fun stuff
ladies and gentlemen Jessica Williams
thank you and so we usually like answer
with a really short shareable less than
140 character response to people but
it's a lot harder to do but we're gonna
have a little battle we're gonna rope
Lois house into this tonight so I'm
gonna try to give you a pithy answer to
whatever your question is but I'll
Mandar all in a bit first so you'll get
a longer answer and we'll get down to it
so your question doesn't have to be
lightning but I'll do my best to come up
with something that's digestible that
you can share hi what's your name are
you problem I live here in San Diego
welcome thanks actually this question is
just for you okay
in the recent family podcast that just
aired Josh you mentioned that you didn't
expect to become a parent yeah yet you'd
open headfirst when you met Rebecca and
Ella right so I'm wondering if you could
share a little about your process before
your feet left the diving board oh yes
so so yeah I'll get there I'll monitor
on a bit and I'll do some editing and
we'll get to it and then I will I will I
will posit your question to them as well
a little bit differently so we can get
something that is tweetable for both of
them
so I think sometimes you you enter a
situation you didn't expect to enter and
when you so with me I met Rebecca a few
years ago she had she had a one-year-old
daughter at the time from a marriage
that had recently ended and we met his
ella was flirting with me at the grocery
store and and it's not that I it's not
that I just didn't expect tonight to
have kids I I knew like emphatically
that wasn't a direction I wanted to go
and so you can imagine my shock at this
point right but so here's here's the
lesson that I learned from me so here's
here's my tweet of why I answer to you
and I'll see if I can expand on it in
order to live the best life we have to
be prepared to change our mind
that's tweetable by the way you're the
judge of this right and and so if I were
to expand on that at all I would just
say that when I met Rebecca I realized
what the circumstance was and I you have
you sort of fork in the road I can
ignore the fact that she has a kid and
and and see how well that's gonna work
for a month or two or I could walk away
from it or three I could I can jump in
and embrace it and also be be really
open and upfront about you know what I
don't know whether or not this is going
to work and I want I want you to know
that but I'm willing to give it a try
and if I'm going to give it a try
man I'm not just gonna dip one toe in
I'm going to dive all the way in and so
so if I were to ask these guys the same
question or a similar question I would
just say have you ever have you ever
there anything you've ever thought one
way about that you've changed your mind
and and it's changed your life for the
better
he said he turned to me before he said
we'll let you go west I'm like why you
looking at I'm just gonna ask you like
no um I mean yeah certainly that that
has happened golly I guess I guess just
thinking about the whole journey to this
like never did I think I would be
willing to have a life off a baristas
salary I mean that was really where this
whole thing started like Josh and I I
was like we were just in this corporate
madness and like we talked about like
okay maybe one day we can open up a
coffee shop like maybe we could do that
but you know before that we would have
to be baristas and like actually know
how to make coffee so um my whole the
whole idea I ad was is art I'm gonna pay
off you know as much debt as I can I'm
going to you know get rid of these crazy
debt payments that I have sold my car
and got rid it got rid of my home and
yeah I got to the point where like I
could and I still could I mean I'd
probably have to move apartments but I
don't I don't have a lease like I could
turn my life on the on a dime right now
and still live off a barista salary if I
absolutely had to like I am I just
became dead free for the first time like
just the last year that was last year
Thanks yeah it's the best feeling in the
world it is I mean that is like for me
that's true freedom it's not being able
to go out and take a you know 30-year
mortgage or to you know go out and rack
up a bunch of student loans like that is
that is not freedom to me anymore so I
certainly have had those those things
change um I was really hoping I cope
with something tweetable by this point I
guess what uh I guess what I would say
and this is just kind of echoes what
what Josh was talking about um it's okay
to close doors but don't be afraid to
open those back up if life calls for
that
Louis has it has there been anything in
your life where you're like okay the
first thing that came to my mind my mind
especially when someone was mentioned
earlier about that actually the first
question that we had when the guy was
saying she was talking about like
knowing when to let go and I thought
like I can only imagine being a
professional athlete and you went
through your old college career knowing
that's what you wanted to do but there
was some point where you had to let go
of that dream in order to make room for
other dreams because if that if that
would still be your only dream today man
your life would be so much different you
talk about that yeah I think I was
trying to think of like a tweetable as
you guys were talking but here's here's
what I think I'm gonna go with something
I used to always focus on to be
successful was really about serving
myself accomplishing my dreams and like
selfish goals and then I realized when I
let go of that and I started to serve
the serve others then it was really more
impactful and more meaningful so I guess
when I let go of serving myself to be
successful to serve others that's when I
really started to make a difference yes
thank you
howdy what's your name Danielle hey
Danielle where you from I live up in
Temecula first of all thank you for
taking that leap of faith to put your
message out there I wish you had come
around about 20 years earlier yeah me
too
everything that remains came into my
life at a really critical turning point
in my life I after reading that book not
solely because of the book but I left a
20-year career that I was miserable in
in the end I was living in Columbus Ohio
at the time go backs and I was able to
take a year off from my life to figure
out me and that those passions but more
importantly I had a family member who
began to fail and I was able to spend
time with them during that year before
they passed and those are that time I
could never imagine I could ever have
the luxury to have that but I realized
my friends and family thought I was nuts
to leave a job to stop paying into my
401k to be living in Columbus Ohio and
many other things but I that book gave
me permission and to not feel guilty and
to to just be able to share that love
with that person who was so special to
me so thank you for that that's I if you
have not read this book something and it
has to resonate with you and and every
time I hear your message something more
resonates with me so thank you but my
question is real quick by the way yeah
we really do have books over there but
if you if you if you can't afford one or
if you just forgot your wallet or
something serious if you can't afford
one and will be happy to buy a copy for
you so if you leave here and you want to
check it out or any of our books you're
welcome to do that we'll buy you one if
you if you can't
speaking of the Leos and the the
Courtney Carver's and you guys I would
love for you all to do a big minimalist
event together that would be awesome but
my question is as you have started
getting rid of your stuff and then you
started your blog together you wrote a
book you started traveling you're doing
events the film's whatever's next how do
you as you keep growing and furthering
in your lives how do you keep that
simpleness in your minimalism with all
of these projects and and the growth and
you're like I think that's the thing I
struggle with is wanting to keep
everything pared down but wanting to
move forward without adding all the
craziness back in yeah so how how do you
how do you maintain a simple life in a
complex world would be
that's the tweetable question by the way
[Music]
man so so I know my short answer has to
do with busyness I mean so back in the
back in the corporate world like it was
it was a badge of honor right I'm busy
busy busy
like someone asked for a meeting I can
I'm busy or hey you got a sec nope I'm
busy
what do you been up to oh man I've been
so busy right I mean and now I hear that
word and it's the worst four-letter word
in our language because busy really just
means out of control so if I ever if you
ever hear me say I'm busy what it's
really saying is my life's out of
control and I found the way to to get
that back is instead of being busy find
a way to be focused and the only way to
be focused is is to is to make sure that
you say no to all of the busy work as
much of it as you can and that you know
what and then say no to some of those
stuff you can't say no to and just see
what happens right because so many of
the things that I thought were essential
were important in my life
when I was 27 don't I don't look back at
and say well those who are not very
important no most of those things were
unimportant they were not important at
all they were non-essential and so my
short answer to you is avoid busy work
enjoy focused work
[Applause]
man um I could I'd walk away from all
this right now I get up at this stage
and leave like if it really if it's
seriously like if that was going to
serve my life better I mean Josh and I
we were on tour in 2014 he started to
have some some health stuff and I'm just
looking at him I'm like dude let's I
think we're on City number like 20 or 30
at that point we had 70 more cities left
I'm like dude do we need to cancel 70
events like I'm totally willing to do
that um
I guess man I've got two short answers
kind of rattling around I guess like any
anything that I put on my plate I can
take it off if I see a hill and I'm like
I'm gonna pick up this Boulder and I'm
gonna walk up this hill
like I know that at any point if it gets
to be too much like I picked that
Boulder up I can set it down I made that
decision to put it on my plate I can I
can clear it off there if I want to and
the other thing too is like I really go
what Josh man we both go out of our way
to focus on one thing a year so you know
2014 it was the 100 City Tour 2015 we
dedicated that year to giving back I
mean we we built schools we built wells
we helped Joshua Becker build orphanages
we supplied schools in Africa with
supplies that they needed in 2016 knows
all about the documentary getting out
there with it this year it's it's this
store and yeah we pod cat we have
podcasts and you know we still write and
things but never do we just like pile it
all on at once and like if Josh and I if
we started from
you know December 2010 saying all right
man we're gonna I'm gonna have a
mentoring business you're gonna have a
writing class but we need to do that
podcast we got to write three books we
have to do that documentary oh also we
got to plan these eight tours in the
next seven years like if that's how we
would have approached it nothing would
have gotten done so I think my short
answer would be I'm gonna go back to the
the boulder thing is like I just think
it's so because there's some
out there right now who's like oh man
there's a big passion project I started
and man I don't you know I don't know
what I'm ever gonna finish that if that
is something that is weighing on that
person then don't do it like we either
do it or don't but don't stress yourself
yourself out over it so I guess any my
short answer would be any Boulder that
we pick up any Boulder we've made the
decision to pick up some people just get
boulder surround them any Boulder that
we've decided to pick up we can make the
decision to put it down what was the
exact question again it's like when you
think about your life in terms of like
how do you keep things simple because I
mean you have this school of greatness
Empire and I mean you you have a staff
you you have I mean you have a wildly
successful podcast do the video stuff
you've written books you've got the
website you you're on Ellen I mean
you're doing all this you don't know it
I think it's pretty awesome and so
you're in Clinton back the other day
that isn't that a we're like the same
week he was on Clinton back in Ellen and
it and what I like about that is you're
talking about stuff that resonates with
with both audiences right it doesn't
it's it's not political and it but but
there's a lot going on there and so how
do you how do you avoid the complexity
how do you avoid getting bogged down and
complexity I think for me it starts with
my vision I'm so clear on my vision of
what I'm trying to create and so every
few months my assistant
like when my closet starts to feel full
I started to get like an itch I just
want to get rid of everything because I
feel like it's too much clutter so I
pretty much wear what these guys wear
every single day I was like I'm not
gonna wear black because that's all I
wear and there'll be three guys with
black Phoenix on so I wore blue instead
right so I wear like the same shirt the
same type of pants pretty much every
single day and I try to have you know
they really inspired me to get rid of
even more
cuz I already thought I was pretty
minimalist you'd been in my place I
really don't have many things and I
always try to get rid of more and have
less I have a 1991 Cadillac Eldorado
that I bought for $4,000 about five
years ago I can buy any car that I want
but I just don't care to have more
things I care to use that to impact more
people and I've got you know all the
clothes that I needed to buy more fancy
clothes I don't wear any watches any
jewelry because I just don't care it
doesn't add value to my life if it did
then maybe I would get those things but
I just don't care so I'm constantly
getting rid of all the clutter in my
space my physical space first so I can
have a clear mind and an open heart and
with that that allows me to have the
most energy and the focus to move
towards my vision because I have a big
vision and I and and a little bit unlike
these guys I put a lot on my plate a lot
of big projects every single year for me
it's not just about one big thing it's
usually like three four or five big
things a year in order to do that and
not be overwhelmed or be out of whack I
have a team that helps manage all these
big projects and I take care of my
health and I take care of all the things
in my life to the best of my ability I'm
not perfect to declutter my mind and my
heart the best of my ability
and that's what I try to focus on when I
have a clean space and I have a clean
mind that I can tackle all powerful
vision it was 139 and then you put a
little bow on that right alright so we
do have time for one more actually we
don't really but we're gonna do we're
gonna squeeze one more in here just for
the see if we can tie everything up here
so everyone can leave happy what's your
name and and where you from I'm Amy I'm
actually visiting from Seattle so I'm
not from just welcome thanks for coming
down yeah um thanks for sharing your
vision I so you speak a lot about
self-actualization and the human
experience is this very you strip it
down to this raw and you just kind of
cleanse everything from your life and I
can't help but wondering
when you look at the root of everything
in the purpose of that if there's
anything what you say there's anything
inherently spiritual or deeply
philosophical but what you do even
watching a documentary I can't say that
I could pinpoint a specific thought or
philosophy or way of life that I could
you know it may be it's just very
open-ended but I just can't help but
wondering if there's something that
draws you back constantly to that yeah I
mean it's been interesting going out on
the road and listening more right I mean
we'll have we had this really nice young
couple come up to us in Jackson
Mississippi and after after one of our
one of our shows and I said you know
it's just great to see a couple of young
Christians out here spread in Jesus's
message yesterday thanks and and then
actually we were in Seattle it was like
a month later and someone came up and
said you know it's great to see these
two guys out here spreading these
Buddhist Maxim's I said hey thanks and
then I later that year I got an email
from someone who said hey did you guys
know that Muhammad was the original
minimalist as I responded with hey
thanks and and what I've learned is that
you minimalism overlays with different
spiritual beliefs in fact Ryan and I
both have different spiritual and
religious beliefs we have a lot of
different beliefs in general and so my
short answer to you is going to be that
no matter your your belief template no
here we go let's let's rewind that
delete delete delete it has to do with
beliefs and values I mean ultimately I
think that the minimalism is a way for
me to get it's a vehicle I use to get to
my values and
the beliefs are a path to those values
so so no matter which road you take
minimalism will help you better
understand your values there we go
so Ryan what about spirituality how do
you how do you how you how you can
answer this short and a short no I I
think that's I mean for some people like
spirituality is it's it's really
important for them and it's what gets
them they'd have no other reason to live
if it wasn't for that spirituality I
know other people who they just don't
have anything inside of them that that
switch well do you know that that where
that switch flips and I've met really
awesome awesome awesome religious people
and I met really really awesome awesome
atheists and I guess what I'll say is uh
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
which prophet you follow or if you
follow a prophet at all living a simple
life is the secret to a good life
so is this going on a self actualization
to religion to spirituality question
yeah okay just wasn't sure where the
question was actually going I think what
we're all looking for is inner peace
yeah why do we go to church why do we
meditate why do we talk about
spirituality is because there's
something we're seeking that we don't
know the answer to or something inside
of us that is stressed out or
overwhelmed because we're so concerned
hurt in pain affected in some way so
we're all seeking inner peace and
acknowledgement and we want to know what
we're doing matters we want to know that
we matter to the world or to the people
around us so for me letting go of [ __ ]
that doesn't matter allows us to have
inner peace and matter
ladies and gentlemen Lewis Howes that
was great all right real quick let's
move on to what we call our our added
value segment this is where Ryan and I
usually talk about the things that are
adding value to our lives recently but
since we're on tour we figured we do
this was a little bit of local Flair
Ryan has there been anything in San
Diego that has added value to your life
today oh man well I went over Mariah and
we went to yeah thank you
nectar we got a smoothie it's pretty
good place I'll say that on the way here
we stopped in Encinitas am I say that
right yeah we stopped at a fish 101
[Applause]
every day un-fuckin'-believable oh my
god so good I mean like we were there
and then just well you know we're
Montana a state where they don't get
fresh fish I mean later doing the river
its kraut
I called Missoula yeah I call Missoula
like that the city of almost like we
almost have a really really good Thai
place we almost have a good sushi place
we almost have this great Indian place
but like it never actually hits a spot
but fish one don't want holy moly if you
haven't been definitely go like
we walked in and they got this huge sea
bass or just like cutting right in front
of this in my mouth like just instantly
starts watering and then there's uh
there's a coffee shop just a couple
miles down the road called Lofty's yeah
lofty lofty yeah so go yeah go go to
lofty like they've got yeah they do a
great for and you know Josh and I well
some of you probably know how Josh and I
are like really you know big coffee
snobs and yeah lofty is it totally meets
our standards so go to fish 101 and then
afterward you go to lofty to get a good
cup of coffee Louis what about you
anything add value to your life today in
San Diego where is the place we went
with salt cow
Sol cow is like a healthy smoothie place
okay and well it said bullet proof
coffee on Yelp uh-huh but then when I
went to get the bulletproof coffee it
wasn't bulletproof coffee it was like a
mixture of all these things that would
have been incredible but I waited about
20 minutes and it started coagulating to
the top and so when I started to drink
it was like hard but Jen my girlfriend
said it was incredible and an added
value to her life because she was
drinking it right away while I was
trying to figure out my Instagram post
well I wanted I wanted to acknowledge
Raley Nicole who opened up the the show
today
and so my partner Rebecca and I are big
Raley Nicole fans in fact rule like
occasion sometimes well like there's a
cabin that will rent out in the middle
of nowhere it's like on the top of a
mountain in the middle of Montana and
like you can't get there without a
four-wheel drive vehicle and the winter
kind of thing and well I go out there
for a long weekend and we'll just put
Raley's album on on repeat and and it's
it's it's good makeout music and so I
know when when Rayleigh and I first
started communicating she said hey
there's a song I think well it'll really
resonate with you and your message and
it's called out loud unapologetically
and I was gonna ask her since she is and
we're doing a local flare of added value
and I've gotten a ton of value out of
out of Raley's music which by the way if
you follow her on Instagram she does a
lot of really great like minute long
covers and in there gorgeous
yeah yeah and they're great so it's just
a trail II Nicole and I think you'll
stay afterward you got some CDs and
stuff over there as well so she's got a
great album called answers and I
encourage everyone to check it out
either the physical copy or wherever you
get digital music these days and
hopefully she'll play a quick song for
us so this is out loud on apologetically
[Music]
stuck in my mind again behind prison of
my point of view
[Music]
when out of time again but somehow I
think I always knew
[Music]
here in I think of starting to see this
life one way for me tomorrow's no
guarantee so starting now I'm gonna live
out now Paulo Jetta Klee
I found success again impressed my
family and my friends too
oh so I come home late it can wait
patient for the day my dreams come true
[Music]
here and I think I'm starting to see
this life away for me
tomorrow's no guarantee so starting now
I'm gonna live out loud you known
apologetically
[Music]
you
[Music]
don't say you don't Sunday don't waste
your life away when you looking back
you'll realize that it wasn't worth it
anyway all the overtime then you got
paid to work on a birthday
and I think I'm starting to see it's not
all that I thought it would be I gotta
get it back to me
so starting now
I'm gonna leave out never on
apologetically
back to the grind again I swear my life
will begin soon thank you yes
raelia Nicole ladies and gentlemen man I
I heard the line about working overtime
on her birthday and I'm like hey can you
please come open up for us so I'd say
Raley is the real deal and I'm just
really really grateful like she you
would be seeing a lot a lot a lot more
from her and I'm grateful you decided to
be here tonight thank you so much all
right real quick let's move on to right
here right now so we talk about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalists
we are in the middle of a 40 city tour
it's called the les is now tour that's
where we are right now but if you're
listening to this at home you can find
all the dates cities theaters all that
fun stuff les is now calm also we're in
the middle of building a podcast studio
and in a film studio as well and we
refuse to clutter our podcast with
advertisements so we could use some help
from you all we started something called
patreon it's where you can donate on a
per episode basis it's like a buck or
two if you're willing to help us do that
none of the money goes to me or Ryan it
just goes to help us pay podcast Shawn a
full-time living wage but also hire a
full-time filmmaker as well so we can do
a lot more video work we really want to
do a lot more and on the video side of
things and we could use your help with
that so if you want to head over to the
minimalists comm and click on a little
donate button up top if you if you can
afford it great if not you can always
leave us a review as well if you'd like
we got anything else going on these days
men no we keep it pretty simple nice
well I want to encourage you to check
out Louis's podcast and obviously it's
called the school of greatness and I
obviously want you to check out his new
book is well as soon as it comes out in
October it's called the masque of
masculinity Louis thank you for being
here and I let me get it one more hug
yeah thanks a lot man
and you can come get one of those hugs
afterward as well Ryan and I are gonna
take about a 20 minute break and then
we'll head over there we'll dish out
some hugs they are optional by the way
they're also free and transferable yes
so you can you can grab one of those and
I just want to thank a few people before
before we head out first off want to
thank the House of Blues for having us
here tonight
and most important I want to thank you I
know it cost you some money to get in
here tonight and we appreciate that it
allows us to pay all the folks that we
need to pay and pay for all the travel
and we used to do these events and
coffee shops and they were free but if
we showed up at lofty with 600 people I
think they'd be pissed at us and so
instead what we're here but you gave up
more than your money you gave up your
two most precious resources your time
and your attention and we're really
grateful for that and so if you leave
here tonight with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks y'all
alright y'all sorry for the quick
interruption but if you want to listen
to our bonus episode this week as well
as all of our past bonus episodes well
you can each week we published the
minimalists private podcast and it's
exclusively for our patreon supporters
and this private podcast shows up in
your normal podcast feed like Apple
podcasts overcast Google Play or
whatever you're listening to right now
however you listen to this podcast that
podcast app you can get our private
podcast on that same podcast app and it
shows up right next to our normal weekly
podcast you know the podcast that you're
listening to right now and I'll tell you
what our answers on those private
podcasts they're often far more intimate
because only a small group of supporters
have access to listening to those
episodes so it allows us to let our hair
down a little bit well Ryan lets his
hair down
mine just gets you know a little bit
taller I guess anyway being a patreon
supporter also gets you first access to
all the best tickets to all of our live
events as well as access to our monthly
private live stream which is called ask
the minimalists anything in which our
patreon supporters get to well ask the
minimalists anything live on video so if
you want to support the minimalist
podcast and receive all the associated
bonus creations head on over to the
minimalists comm and click
the donate button at the top of the page
on that page you'll find links to
support us on on patreon on a per
episode basis and that will allow you to
receive all of those patreon exclusives
or you can also contribute just one time
via PayPal or VIN moe
you'll see the links there on that same
donate page at the minimalists com now
let me be clear I think it's worth
noting that none of this money goes to
me and none of it goes to Ryan instead
we're using your contributions to build
a new podcast and film studio in Los
Angeles and that's gonna allow us to
create more meaningful audio and video
creations for the entire world if you
already support this podcast I just want
to say thank you I know that $2 may not
sound like a lot of money it's I mean
it's less than a cup of coffee and in
most cities but your support but it is
your support that keeps this podcast
100% advertisement free because
advertisements suck
thanks to your listenership we have one
of the largest podcasts in the world and
if we can just get 2% of our audience to
support this show then we'll have enough
funds to produce some amazing new
creations for years to come
your support is truly appreciated
alright y'all back to the regular show
hello this is DC from Minneapolis
Minnesota and I just want to quickly
recommend something that added a lot of
value to my life for a while it's a
website called unroll me un rol LM e and
you just enter your email address and it
pulls up every single email list you're
subscribed to and then you can easily
look at the listeners click unsubscribe
from all these email lists that's a lot
easier than scrolling to the bottom of
an email and finding the unsubscribe
button so yes that's helping me a lot
lately ha this is Cindy Clough from
Sharpsburg Georgia just south of Atlanta
but my message is an encouragement to
Kenny from the small stuff podcast
recorded in Spokane
Kenny mentioned that she had a paper
issue in fact a four drawer
filing cabinet full of sentimental paper
I can identify with her predicament
because I had the same problem a few
years of them I had a four door file
cabinet full of memory papers travel
articles pulled from magazines
warranties and other such pieces of
paper the impetus that drove me to go
through that filing cabinet was a new
for better space to store our
backpacking equipment our equipment was
scattered through our home and we knew
it would make it simpler to get out on
the trail if everything was just in one
spot we could organize impact quickly I
decided that I'd rather have the space
to pack easily than to have drawer full
of these articles from places we wanted
to visit to facilitate this change I
realized that the computer would be my
friend I scan some papers I typed into
Google Docs some of the information a
list of all the travel destinations ends
tours here and other travel information
and then use Vigo to save the web pages
that would be pertinent in this part I
realized that some of the ends towards
and information we're not even in
business or they moved certainly in the
prices and details have changed now I
have all the current updated information
at my fingertips it took me almost a
year to finish the project but
eventually I was able to get rid of all
the paper and then the filing cabinet
itself and yes we do get out on the
trail more and travel to all those
places for which I've been filing
information and you go file by phone
in fact I watch TV Ron did some of this
I celebrated after each drawer and it
was a small celebration just to take out
a few files to the garage and either
shred or recycle the paper encourage
came in to just begin the project kami
you're going to feel so much lighter
once it's all done set your timer for 15
minutes or one television show get as
much done as you can during that time
and then stop if you're tired or
continue on if you're on a roll
do not give up remember it'll be a
one-time job after going through all
that paper I can assure you you will not
want to save any other pieces of paper I
wish you success and better use of your
space hi this is Jamie from Cincinnati
I just gave my parents a Christmas gift
and
is full of inside jokes I thought I
might read it on the chance that might
give one of your listeners an idea as we
approach this season of getting there we
go
Merry Christmas you have just received
in Monday but note redeemable only on a
Monday as that it's the only day I have
child care other than you I know you
don't really need any more stuff this
Christmas though instead I will take a
vacation day to help you do whatever you
want eat the grass cut I'll cut it
leaves right in bed need heavy stuff
moved or someone to stand on a ladder to
paint want the old time machine dusted
I'm your girl need a haircut or toenails
clipped but note does not include
maintenance of the dead toe put it on
the list want to get an early start on
Christmas lights or need an extra
minivan to haul stuff away computer
health photo help someone to drive you
to bowling the gym or help run other
errands want me to watch lifetime movies
with you while shredding tons of little
bills count me in bring on the job list
this gift also includes dinner with me
in a restaurant of your choice and you
don't even have to bring your own coupon
or choose from the two-for-one menu
approximate value of total package 1
million US dollars so what I do help my
parents on a regular basis but with
small children the gift of this much
dedicated time it's truly a gift to them
I know my mom is already busy thinking
of tasks for me and my dad is happy that
a few things might actually move from
his lips to mine they really don't need
any more things and we're happy to
receive my note so I'm thinking I may
have actually started a new tradition
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
[Music]
you